a controversial message today from the  vatican saying the catholic church  cannot bless  same-sex unions father anthony figaro is  the vatican consultant for cbs news  he says the vatican decree is a strong  affirmation of traditional church  doctrine if we bless  a union we're actually putting them on a  par  with marriage that for the church  is outside what god intended  in creation he says pope francis has  gone further than any other pontiff  in welcoming and accepting people in the  lgbtq community  but when priests came to the vatican to  clarify if blessing same-sex unions is  allowed  the answer was no pope francis said this  was not  unjust discrimination but rather a  clarification  of the liturgical right of marriage